ce monsieur x après writer acteurs
painter maintenant lunettes s'attaque au
footballeur rocheteau pas de carton
jaune pour l'ange vert ou blanc
dominique rocheteau bonsoir combien
d'années de carrière je fais 15 ans 15
ans de carrière
combien de matchs joués sa seule image
ça c'est à peu près 500 matches comme
une sélection en équipe de france j'ai
fait 49 sélections j'ai raté la 50e
contre l'allemagne en demi-finale de la
coupe du monde combien de buts marqués
je marquais à peu près 150 buts en
championnat de france et les saisons
vécues comme un carton jaune carton
rouge
ben ça c'est un peu
ça peut affecter parce que je crois que
j'ai pas pris de carton jaune en
championnat frange jeune je fais un
carton jaune avec l'équipe de france où
il faut pas que ça ait fait banon
mais bon c'était pas grave en bas un tu
fais quoi aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il ya quelques années si on
les 10 avril jamais pensé pouvoir faire
ça mais je pensais pas rester en
football et puis finalement c'est quand
même un milieu c'est mieux que je
connais je connais le plus que je
connais bien et j'ai décidé de m'occuper
de la carrière des joueurs de bonne
figure on a monté une société de
management ça fait l'écho sport j'aurais
pu faire de la politique toi tu es très
politique - trop politique
ouais bah tu as toujours dit tant
attirance pour che guevara du moment où
la ligue c'était un moment que tu es que
l'extrême gauche les bruits que tu t'es
intéressé à la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire alliant chevrier indices
y ont droit pendant matériaux mais assez
à gauche assez à l'extrême gauche quand
m autrement vous avez envie de militer
contre la norme et mitterrand c'est
après des travaux mitterrand c'était
quand même l'extrême gauche c'était
quand même pas reprocher non non non tu
pars progrès non non c'est vraiment ça
ça fait vraiment ce qui se passe au
niveau d'inconscience
c'était plus arlette laguiller françois
mitterrand dès mardi
ce qui est évident plus tôt au moment
des élections de 80 lui dit quand même
un truc assez c'est énorme s'est dit si
si la droite passe la démocratie sera en
danger
est ce que tu crois vraiment géré sans
porter de jugement sur les candidats
golfweek nasa sans porter de jugement
sur les candidats qui étaient en
présence non juré est ce que tu penses
vraiment que si chirac réélu la
démocratie aurait été en danger
non il tout l'extrême droite où il avait
dit la droite fait je crois que plus que
la politique si c'était à refaire tu
aurais fait de la chanson de l'adhésion
de la musique en général non la chanson
dont la musique est rude mais c'était à
refaire tue près ça
monter sur une scène
jouer dans un jouet dans un groupe comme
à la grande époque de la rue schuman ya
justement quand on s'en tape les l'ange
vert ce kit énerver beaucoup d'ailleurs
rien me dire
ouais hein oui ça que je suis vraiment
une image mais tape une côté un peu
comme ça c'est gentil un peu trop gentil
ouais on m'a souvent dit je t'ai trop
gentil je crois que dans la vie est trop
gentil c'est pas c'est pas pour ça c'est
pas vraiment un des points délecte de
fret et de gonzague a carrément dérivé
d'un gta rivera l'espagne dévie une
image ça marche je suis longe by colo
symbole des années 70 un que c'est bien
c'est pas reproche la toile je passais
ma 6ème masi très bien et quand même une
large de manière fait exister quand même
un monde
pour les postes de saint-etienne reste
est assez fou d'ailleurs
enfin pour moi il me semblait que
c'était un peu un peu démesuré pas non
plus jamais du foot on fait un sport et
là c'était sale et pris des proportions
énormes
descendu les champs elysées alors qu'on
avait perdu la vie à un jeune de rock
français même quand ils perdent on a
décidé ce truc mais tu parles est
toujours beaucoup de la californie à
l'école j'aurais voulu vivre sur la côte
ouest
bah moi c'est un endroit où je me sens
vraiment le mieux c'est bon c'est mon
pays c'est les charentes
g
aussi la tâche ray mais c'est surtout là
pour tous les états unis surtout la côte
ouest
je sais pas là bas je sais pas je le
sens bien
bon niveau de la musique /
j'en profite un maximum est de voir des
groupes les groupes que j'aime ça aurait
fallu plusieurs vis tellement non tu
recevras quand ça va bien tu es prêt
pour écouter de la musique californienne
on va essayer way